you co-authored a paper you mentioned
lee smolin
uh titled the
autodidactic universe
which describes our universe as one that
learns its own physical laws
that's a trippy and beautiful powerful
idea
what are what would you say are the key
ideas in this paper ah okay well i
should say
that paper reflected work from last year
and the project the program has moved
quite a lot so it's a little there's a
lot of stuff that's not published that
i'm quite excited about so i have to
kind of keep my frame in that in that uh
last year's thing so i have to try to be
a little careful about that
we can think about it in a few different
ways um
the core of the paper the the technical
core of it is a triple correspondence
one part of it was
already established and then another
part is in the process the part that was
established
was um of course understanding different
theories of physics as matrix models the
part that
was
fresher is understanding those as a
machining machine learning system so
that we could move fluidly between these
different ways of describing systems and
the reason to want to do that is to just
have more tools and more options because
um uh well theoretical physics is really
hard and a lot of programs have kind of
um
run into a state where they feel a
little stalled i guess i can i i want to
be delicate about this because i'm not a
physicist i'm the computer scientist
collaborating so
um i don't mean to diss anybody's so
this is almost like gives a framework
for generating new ideas and physics as
you as we start to publish more about
where it's gone i think you'll start to
see there's there's tools
and ways of thinking about
theories that
i think open up some new paths uh that
that will be of interest um
there's the technical core of it which
is this idea this idea of a
correspondence to give you more facility
but then there's also the storytelling
part of it and this is something
um
lee loves stories and i do and the idea
here is that
uh a typical
way of thinking about physics is that
there's some kind of starting condition
and then there's some principle by which
the starting
condition evolves
and the question is like why the
starting condition like how how
oh the starting condition has to get
kind of per this has to be fine-tuned
and all these things about it have to be
kind of
perfect and so we were thinking well
look what if we could push the
storytelling about where the universe
comes from much further back by starting
with really simple things that evolve
and then through that evolution explain
how things got to be how they are
through very simple principles right and
so we've been um exploring a variety of
ways to push the the start of the
storytelling further and further back
which um and it's an interesting
it's really kind of interesting because
like uh
um for all of his lee is uh sometimes
considered to be
um to have a radical quality in the
physics world but um
uh he still is like no this is gonna be
like
the kind of time we're talking about
which evolution happens is the same time
we're now and we're talking about
something that starts
and continues and i'm like well what if
there's some other kind of time that's
time-like and well that sounds like
metaphysics but there's an ambiguity you
know like
it has to start from something and it's
kind of an interesting so there's this
uh
a lot of the math can be thought of
either way which is kind of interesting
so it pushes so far back that basically
all the things we take for granted and
physics start becoming and emerge
i really want to emphasize it's all
super baby steps i don't want to over
claim it's like it's i i think a lot of
the things we're doing we're approaching
some old problems in a pretty fresh way
informed
there's been a zillion papers about how
you can think of the universe as a big
neural net or how you can think of
different ideas and physics as being
quite similar to or even equivalent to
some of the ideas in machine learning
and uh that actually works out crazy
well like i mean it that is actually
kind of eerie when you look at it like
uh
there's probably
two or three dozen papers that have this
quality and some of them are just crazy
good and it's very it's very interesting
what we're trying to do is is
take those kinds of observations and
turn them into an actionable framework
where you can then start to
do things with landscapes or theories
that you couldn't do before and that
sort of thing
you